Welcome back.
Well, in the last video we
took the Maclaurin series for
cosine of x, the Maclaurin
series representation.
So I guess we might as well
do the same for sine of x.
And I'm sounding very
nonchalant, but I have a reason
behind why I'm doing this, and
you'll see in a few videos from
now, when we come up with
the grand conclusion.
So anyway, let's
just set up f of x.
And you might just want to do
this yourself instead of
watching me do it, because it
should be pretty
self-explanatory now that you
saw cosine of x.
And then you could
check your work.
You can pause right now, and
then you can check to see
that we got the same answer.
You'll probably be right
and I probably made
a careless mistake.
So f of x is equal
to sine of x.
First of all, let's just
figure out all of the
derivatives of sine of x.
We can already guess that it
probably cycles similar to
cosine of x, with
slight variation.
So what's the derivative
of sine of x?
Well, that's just cosine of x.
What's the second derivative?
I'm just going to stop
putting parentheses
around these numbers.
The second derivative, well,
that's just derivative of that.
It's minus sine of x.
The third derivative of x.
Well, I guess I'll put the
parentheses so you don't think
it's f to the third times x.
The third derivative, well,
that's just going to be the
minus cosine, rightu0008?
Because the derivative of sine
is cosine, but then we have
that minus sine there.
And the fourth derivative.
The derivative of cosine is
minus sine, but we have a minus
there, so we get back to sine.
And then the cycle continues.
So the fifth derivative is just
going to be cosine of x, or
just the derivative
of the sine of x.
And then the cycle
continues, right?
All right.
So we know the derivatives,
and we can just keep going.
So let's evaluate the
derivatives of our function
of sine of x at x equals 0.
f of 0.
Well, that's sine of zero.
What's sine of 0?
Well, sine of 0 is 0.
f prime of 0 is equal
to cosine of 0.
That's equal to 1.
The second derivative at 0,
that's minus sine of 0.
Well, sine of 0 is still 0.
So that's 0.
You can see it's a very similar
pattern to what we saw in the
Maclaurin series
for cosine of x.
And then the third
derivative evaluated at 0.
That's cosine of 0 is 1.
But we have a minus sine,
so that's minus 1.
This you already know.
The fourth derivative is 0.
Sine of 0 is 0.
And then it starts
to cycle again.
The fifth derivative,
0 equal to 1.
So we start with 0, then
positive 1, then 0, then minus
1, then 0, then positive 1.
Every other number is a 0.
Every other, I guess you could
say, coefficient in the
Maclaurin series is a 0.
The coefficient when you don't
include the factorial term.
And then the ones in between
oscillate between positive
1 and negative 1.
So what would be the Maclaurin
series for sine of x?
The Maclaurin series
representation?
So we could say that sine of x
-- And remember, I haven't
proven to you that the
Maclaurin series representation
of sine of x or cosine of x or
e to the x really is equal to
those functions over
the entire domain.
I might do that later.
Frankly, I've been thinking
about the proof myself.
It hasn't been completely
intuitive how to do that proof.
Although if you test them
out, it does seem to
make a lot of sense.
But you shouldn't just
take my word for it.
I'm going to look up the
proof and I will prove
it to you, eventually.
But for now, you just have to
take it as a bit of a leap of
faith that the Maclaurin series
representations just don't
approximate those functions
around 0, that when you take
the infinite series, it
actually equals the function.
So sine of x.
The Maclaurin series
representation is going to be
equal to -- well, f of 0,
that's 0 plus f of -- so the
first derivative, it's going to
be 1 times x to the 1 over 1
factorial, which is just 1.
This is just 1.
And then we have -- this is
just plus 0 -- and then we have
minus -- and now this is the
third derivative -- so, minus 1
times x to the third
over 3 factorial.
And then you have a 0.
Then we have a plus 1.
And this is now the fifth
derivative, so x to the
fifth over five factorial.
And we'll just keep going, but
I think you see the pattern
as we write and rewrite it.
Sine of x is equal to 0, so we
get x to the first, so that's
just x minus x to the third
over 3 factorial plus x to
the fifth over 5 factorial.
And then you can
imagine the pattern.
We'd go minus -- we're just
taking the odd numbers -- x to
the seventh over 7 factorial
plus x to the ninth over 9
factorial minus x to the
eleventh over 11 factorial,
and we'll just keep going.
And so we'll just keep
oscillating in sine -- that's
a bit of a pun -- and we use
all of the odd exponents.
So if I were to write that in
sigma notation, and sigma
notation often is
the hard part.
Well once again, the first
term, when the term is 0 --
this is the first term, right
-- we get a positive sine.
Because we're going to
oscillate in sine, we're
probably going to take
negative 1 to some power.
It'll be negative 1
to the n plus 1.
So let's see if that works.
If this is the first term,
this will be a -- no,
no, no, that won't work.
It'll be to the 2n plus 1.
Actually, I think I should
have done that in the
previous video, too.
I think it should have been
negative 1 to the 2n,
not negative 1 to the n.
I'm sorry for that mistake.
So it's negative 1 to the 2n
plus 1 times x to the 2n.
Oh, no, no, sorry, I was
right in the previous video.
See, I'm confusing
myself, because I don't
count the 0 terms.
It would probably help me to
write the sigma down first.
So this is equal to -- as you
can see I do all of this in
real time -- infinity
from n is equal to 0.
And so, the first term is
positive, so it'll be
negative 1 to the n, right?
Because negative 1 to the
0 power is 1, right?
So that's positive and then the
second term is negative, then
positive, negative, right?
And so, the zeroth term is x,
so it has to be x to the --
let me see -- 2n plus 1.
Does that work?
Right, because the first
term would then be 3.
Right. x to the 2n plus 1
over 2n plus 1 factorial.
It's almost easier when you
just write it out like that.
Well, that's pretty
interesting.
But what's even more
interesting is if you see the
similarity between the
Maclaurin series representation
for sine of x, and then the
representation we figured
out for cosine of x in
the previous video.
We figured out that cosine of x
is equal to 1 minus x squared
over 2 factorial plus x to the
fourth over 4 factorial minus x
to the sixth over six factorial
plus x to the eighth
over 8 factorial.
So they're almost the
opposite, right?
They almost complement
each other.
The cosine, these are all of
the even exponents, right?
And even factorials.
And sine is all of the odd
exponents, because this
is x to the 0, right?
So that's why you get 1 here.
And in sine, it's all of the
odd exponents and all of the
odd factorials in
the denominator.
So that by itself, I
think, is pretty neat.
What is especially neat, just
another fodder for thought, is
that we know from trigonometry
that sine is just a shifted
cosine function or that cosine
is just a shifted
sine function.
But what's neat is by shifting
it by pi over 2 -- which is all
they are, right, if you were to
graph it, they're just shifted
90 degrees to the left or the
right of each other -- you can
actually represent them
differently by essentially
picking the odd or even terms
of this factorial polynomial
series, whatever you
want to call it.
But anyway.
Doesn't matter if you didn't
understand what I said at
the end, as long as you
appreciate how cool this is.
I will see you in
the next video.